Hillside gives way in Northern
California as the state reels from the
impact of powerful back-to-back storms
rain wind and high water have caused
widespread damage evacuations and
several deaths
35 million Californians are under a
flood alert tens of thousands are
without power and others face flooding
mudslides and the danger of falling
trees several major highways are blocked
a lot of runoff a lot of dangerous flash
flooding potential with the system and
there's also high winds President Joe
Biden has declared a state of emergency
in parts of California which will allow
federal aid and resources to flow in
more quickly one of the worst hit areas
was here in Santa Cruz where as you can
see behind me the historic Capitola
Wharf was cutting two by heavy surf
Rivers also overflowed their Banks and
high winds caused severe damage in shops
and homes
the cost of the damage is still being
counted but it will certainly run into
the tens of millions of dollars
further south near Santa Barbara the
upscale community of Montecito was
evacuated the celebrity studied towns
ten thousand residents include the Duke
and Duchess of Sussex and Oprah Winfrey
the flash flood situation is now the
potential is there for county-wide flash
flooding and so please stay vigilant in
Santa Cruz County 32 thousand people
were evacuated when the swollen San
Lorenzo River spilled over its banks at
least a dozen people have died in the
storms Maria cuchiara barely escaped a
similar fate a huge Branch harpooned my
roof and I live in a small Studio
so
I have two kitties
and we could have been killed residents
are frustrated by widespread road
closures can't make it to work it's like
a like a rat trying to get out of a maze
trying to find the different little
route to get through five massive
weather systems called atmospheric
Rivers have rolled in off the Pacific in
recent days
more rain is forecast for the rest of
the week
the only benefit for Californians is
heavy snowfall in the mountains which
will help relieve the state's severe
drought Rob Reynolds Al Jazeera Santa
Cruz California